this is not a landfill
this was versiva beach in mumbai india a
little over three years ago
it was covered in over 6 000 tons of
trash
after what the united nations called the
world's largest beach cleanup this is
versafa beach today
it was a movement started and led by one
man
afros shaw
[Music]
my name is afrosh i'm a lawyer by
profession and i love oceans in october
of 2015 versova beach was little more
than a dumping ground on the west coast
of mumbai there were five and a half
feet of plastic and when you see so much
plastic object opposed to the ocean it's
scary it's very scary
we have devastated the health of our
ocean
garbage pile up either on land or an
ocean is a big issue not only in india
world over
so afros took matters into his own hands
he started picking up the trash himself
i have spent my childhood here you know
i used to play her and the beach used to
be very very clean for me it was purely
simple it had to be my personal journey
then i told myself it will be difficult
for a single man to do it so i said why
not take this personal journey to others
i provoked others to join in and
eventually did join me
since 2015 every weekend hundreds of
volunteers join afros to pick up the
trash that has been strewn along a two
mile stretch of the beach
and the volunteer work continues today
we have been cleaning for past 112 weeks
now and it's almost 9 million kgs of
plastic and filth out from the ocean
beach cleaning is one of the biggest
preventive action
to prevent this plastic going into the
deep sea this is minimum we can do
so the use of trucks
bulldozers buckets whatever people can
use
the beach has slowly been picked up
but the issue is more than just the
beach
it's about the mindset of people so
apart from the beach cleanup afros also
works with local communities to help
educate them on recycling and proper
trash disposal
we go to coastal communities where you
know the littering happens talking to
them i go to people's garbage i tell
them show me
then i tell them how to segregate how to
handle plastic this is the first creek
which is entering into the ocean from
here
i'm proud that i'm connecting with
people and i'm connected to nature that
gets a very big sense of pride in my
heart you know
[Music]
this problem of pollution is created by
us we've lost a sense of belonging to
our planet and to our ocean
a lot of people ask me of course how
long you're going to clean
the day we say that this ocean is mine
and it has to be [ __ ] and span will not
ask this question in fact we'll go and
provoke others to do what i'm doing
we are in for a long haul and every
citizen on this planet must be in for a
long haul
start doing your bit what we're doing
[Music]
key
[Music]